Good day, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the University
of Southern California, and please allow me
to
welcome you to "The Big Data to Knowledge,
Guide to the Fundamentals of Data Science"
seminar series.
Today,
we have Ananth Grama from Purdue University,
and Mehmet Koyuturk from Case Western Reserve
University,
who will be discussing their work on the theoretical
foundations of software infrastructure for
biological network
databases.
One of our two speakers, Ananth Grama, is
the Samuel Conte Professor of Computer Science
at Purdue
University, where he has areas of research
in the domain of high performance computing,
large scale data
analytics, and computational biology, where
he has authored numerous papers and coauthored
a textbook,
entitled Introduction to Parallel Computing,
Design and Analysis of Algorithms.
He received his PhD from the
University of Minnesota in 1996 and has been
at Purdue ever since that time.
Mehmet Koyuturk received his PhD in 2006 in
computer science from Purdue University, and
received his
bachelor of science and his master's degree
from Bilkent University in electrical engineering
and computer
engineering.
He's now currently a professor in the Department
of Electrical Engineering and Computer Science
at
Case Western Reserve University, and holds
secondary appointment at the Center for Proteomics
and
Bioinformatics at Case Western School of Medicine.
His research focuses on the analysis of biological
networks,
system biology of complex diseases, and computational
genomics.
Finally, he is also an associate editor for
the
IEEE ACM Transactions on Computational Biology
and Bioinformatics.
We're very excited to have them discussing
their work today.
And as always, I'd like to invite our audience
members to submit any questions that they
have during the presentation via the go-to
webinar question
submission system.
It's located in the little panel, usually
over on the right side of your screen.
During the last 10
minutes of the hour, we'll go through-- or
I will go through those and ask those questions
on your behalf.
Without
further ado, I'd like to welcome Ananth and
Mehmet, and tell them to take the stage.
The stage is yours,
gentlemen.
Thank you, Jake.
This is Mehmet Koyuturk.
Hello, everyone.
Good morning, good afternoon, or good evening,
depending on where you are.
So we are happy to be talking about the effort
on building network databases, which
aims to enable integrated query both biological
networks in real time.
And I will start by motivating what we mean
by that.
What we mean by creating biological networks
and what we
mean by biological networks, after all.
So if we think about the big data of biology,
which people usually call Omics
in the context of the [INAUDIBLE] of biology,
we have access to data on DNA.
We have access to data on RNA, in
terms of both, the abundance of gene expression
profiles in a transcription sample.
And also RNA structure,
alternative splicing, and so on.
And then also, at the protein level, we can
measure protein expression, look at protein
structure.
And then at the
functional level, we can look at protein-protein
interactions, post-translational modification
of proteins, metabolites,
and so on and so forth.
And these give rise to [INAUDIBLE] and we
can also measure those things at a very large
scale, in terms of the phenom types like bio
mass, disease state, clinical outcome, and
so on and so forth.
So in the context of precision medicine, one
important goal is to be able to integrate
the exomic data to make
sense of human diseases, for example.
And it's important to note that most of this
data can be represented or
naturally comes in the form of networks.
And indeed, there are lots of biological databases
out there.
And these networks contain different types
of information, in terms of the interactions
and associations between
biomolecules.
But not just by biomolecules, also different
entities that can be thought of in the context
of biological
data analysis.
So for example, protein-protein interactions
are one form of network data.
Then you have
information on the physical binding of different
proteins.
And this is usually obtained through high
throughput
experiments, but also protein interactions
can be predicted using computational tools.
Then protein DNA interactions gives an idea
about regulatory-- transcriptional regulation,
and other regulatory
interactions.
Small molecule and protein interactions, again,
give an idea about regulation of proteins,
posttranslational
regulation of proteins.
Enzyme-substrate interactions, put in the
context of metabolic [INAUDIBLE],
also in the context of post-translational
modification of proteins.
So these are really at the biological, at
the cellular
level, interactions that can be represented
as networks.
But going beyond that, also between genes,
we can talk about functional or statistical
interactions.
So for example,
if two genes are known to take part in the
same process, that's a functional interaction
between the genes.
Or
statistical interactions.
For example, if two genes show up in the same
context, if they are expressed together in
the same context, then this is a statistical
interaction, and it has value to be included
in a natural context in a
network database.
And again, functional interactions between
genomic elements, for example, synthetic lethality.
You knock out one
gene in the cell, the cell doesn't die.
You knock out the other one, the cell doesn't
die.
But when you knock out
both, the cell dies.
This is a functional interaction.
Again, all these functional interactions can
be represented as
networks.
Finally, not just these statistical or physical
interactions, but also associations-- observed
and inferred
associations-- between different biological
entities can also be represented as networks.
For example, genotypephenotype
associations.
If one gene is identified as being implicated,
or as being associated in a particular
disease, then that is an interaction, or that's
an association, between the gene and the disease.
And for example, the OMIM database-- the Online
Mendelian Inheritance in Man database-- contains
this kind of
information.
And that database can be thought of as a biological
network database.
Similarly, the functional
associations among molecules, the evolutionary
relationships between genes, can all be represented
in the form
of networks.
So what you are looking at here, from a paper
that was published in 2011, is a regionalization
of different types of
biological networks and the interactions between
them.
Essentially, different types of biological
network databases
contain different types of biological network
information.
They do interact with each other, but the
information that
they convey-- the information that they are
focused on-- is different for different databases.
And people have done
enough with these network databases.
So for example, by constructing disease gene
networks, researchers are able to transfer
knowledge on genes
implicated in different diseases to prioritize
genes to look for another disease.
And you can do this, really, by
looking at the clinical symmetry between the
diseases, looking at the functional similarity
between the genes, and
also looking at the associations between the
diseases.
You can put these all in a network context,
and then use
that network context to transfer information.
So similarly, the concept of phenologs is
based on the representation of evolutionary
relationships between genes
in the form of a network.
And then making influences on which genotypes,
in which organisms, match to each
other.
So we have done a lot of work on identifying
tissue-specific networks, or identifying and
uncovering the
relationship between genes that are mutated
in cancers versus that are transcriptionally
dysregulated in cancers,
again, using network context.
But the bottom line is, although these applications
have been successful,
researchers who do this kind of research--
you don't always need to go to each different
database.
As I said,
different network databases contain different
types of network information.
So if they will use three types or four types
of different network information, they will
need to go to each database,
download the data from their [INAUDIBLE],
and then they will have to develop algorithms
at home in their own
labs to preprocess, to integrate, and then
to analyze these data so they can make inferences.
One question that
we are exploring in this webinar, and also
in our project that was supported by this
big data initiative, is how far
are we from integrated querying of biological
data?
That is, can we do these tasks which have
been shown to be
successful again and again-- can we do them
by just going to the web and without needing
to connect to all these
databases?
Querying the databases at once, in real time,
all together for such sophisticated querying
tests.
So as you listen to us, really, I will ask
you to think about this question again and
again.
Because we will describe
several efforts toward this end.
And of course, if you are trying to provide
a fast, efficient, and stable querying
infrastructure for a network, the first thing
that you need to have is a network database.
And now I will pass the
microphone to Professor Grama, and he will
talk about one of the network databases that--
the database systems
that we are trying to develop.
All right.
So the rest of the talk is organized as follows.
I will spend the next few minutes describing
the software
aspects of this database, all of its features
and the benefits of using this database over
any of the other databases
that you might have encountered.
And then we'll talk about some specific network
algorithms, and then we'll
conclude with some examples of how you might
use an infrastructure like this.
So the one condition here is that you have
interaction data that can have millions of
nodes and edges.
The
networks themselves are continuously updated.
There are many different versions of these
networks.
Networks
are present dynamic systems.
So you have to have some integration of molecular
data.
You have to capture network dynamics.
And the key
question that you're posed with is can you
build a scalable, integrated graph system
that supports versioning, that
supports integrated querying, that supports
analytics, all in place, without requiring
users to install all of these
different tools?
So this effort, for us, led into the development
of what is called Trueno.
This is our hybrid graph
datastore/computational engine.
I'll try to impress upon you that this does
have a tremendous set of features for a
diverse set of applications.
So this is a database that's meant to run
in the cloud.
It is distributed.
It's resilient.
And
it's a fast static graph store.
When I say static, it means that once you've
integrated the data into the store, the data
becomes available for
analytics.
Static that's here doesn't mean that you can't
update the data.
It actually support versioning, it supports
dynamic networks.
It supports distributed computations.
It supports online queries, traversals, analytics.
It scales
to very, very large network databases.
And when I say large, I mean billions of nodes
and edges is what we have tested these to.
There's literally a
three-mouse-click setup for both cluster and
single instance installations for these things.
And it provides a very
powerful, friendly, and intuitive interface
for network analysis.
It's got a library of tools that already are
built into it.
And it has hooks for visualization, both to
other tools and a visualization module built
into the database.
All right.
So many of you might have used other databases,
Neo4j, OrientDB, Titan.
These are commonly used
databases.
And Trueno does a good job of supporting a
number of features that we set out.
You know, first of all,
it's a free open source distributed version.
You can-- at the end of this talk, there'll
be a GitHub repository where
you can download this from.
It's easy start.
Like I said, literally about three mouse clicks
will get you started.
It's got multi-language connectors.
You can program Trueno queries and applications
in a rich class of languages.
It's scalable, in terms of
visualization.
Supports GPU-based visualization rendering.
It's got a rich collection of built-in algorithms
for
analysis.
And finally, it supports dynamic graphs.
All right.
So it turns out this is a tremendously sophisticated
piece of code, and there's no way any of us
would
write something like this from the ground
up.
So it does leverage a number of existing systems.
At the bottom of it
is a storage layer, which is Cassandra.
This is a p-value store that is actually quite
commonly used in such cloudbased
applications.
On top of it is a visualization layer.
You have hooks to commonly-used tools such
as Cytoscape and Sigma js.
There is a computational layer that gets your
interface into a very common graph interface
called GraphX, and
NetworkX, as well.
And there are language bindings that are supported,
as well.
The architecture of Trueno is shown here.
At the top level, it's got a couple of interfaces.
It's got an interface with
Gremlin.
This is a language for intuitive and easy
attraction with the graph database.
It's got a web console, which
means that if you didn't want to actually
ever code anything, there's a nice web-based
interface, as well.
There's a Trueno core.
This is essentially what we developed, which
is essentially the core of how graphs are
organized, how graphs are versioned, how you
interface with the front end.
And of course, underneath Trueno
core, we use everything from Elasticsearch,
which is an indexing technique for fast search.
We use Spark, which
is a data processing system used for a distributed
graph processing.
In our case, GraphX, specifically.
And of
course, at the bottom of all of this is Cassandra,
which is a scalable and high availability
common store database.
All right.
So the storage schema here is as follows.
Each keyspace is a graph.
We have distributed workloaded
storage.
You can choose to replicate your data for
increased availability.
And this is something a user can control.
Data is, in fact, sharded, which means that
it is actually broken in little pieces across
different nodes in the cloud.
And this is to make sure that you have horizontal
scaling.
In other words, if you want more throughput,
sharding
gives you more throughput by aligning with
more nodes to get you the data.
It supports multiple properties on
edges and vertices.
So for example, if your attractions have properties,
you can put them on edges, [? vertices ?] themselves.
These
maybe expression profiles that you can store
on vertices.
And finally, analytics results is stored in
graph structure,
as well, for easy post-processing analysis.
I'm going to go through this a little quickly,
as Mehmet already mentioned this.
The way people normally work
now, you go to a database, you download your
data, you write analytics in C++ or Java or
Python typically lead to
a graph library.
You see your results and go from there.
And what we're looking to do, really, is to
integrate all of
that into a store so that you can significantly
accelerate and make easy the process of compute,
visualize, and
analyze your results.
This is a typical execution flow for happens
inside Trueno.
You get a query.
This could be something along the
lines of g.v, which will simply give you all
the vertices in the graph g, or g.e, which
will give you all the edges in the
graph.
The Gremlin server pulls all the data from
the back end.
At this point, you might choose to just visualize
it,
or you can look at one of the other key features
here.
All of these things are scheduled.
The analytics tasks are scheduled completely
transparent to you on all of the
cloud resources that are available.
And there is a rich set of functionality that
goes with this thing, as well.
The language connectors that you have available,
you can program this thing in Python, Node.js,
Java Script,
Java, what have you-- Scala.
So it's a very rich set of languages that
are supported, which all get transparently
executed on this graph database.
The installation is easy.
Like I said, a few mouse clicks will install
this thing for you.
The data import uses an import
tool to load graphs from JSON-formatted files.
This is not sophisticated.
It can be very easily done.
The compute
server allows execution of algorithms in a
graph within a few clicks.
There are examples in the GitHub page where
we show that very commonly used tools can
be instantiated within a very small number
of clicks, as well.
It relies on a very fast graph analytic visualization
user interface, which lets you interactively
explore the graph, as
well, in addition to any analytics queries
that you might choose to write.
So this is an example of what a query
might look like.
So like I said, feel free to go to the GitHub
repository.
There's a complete documentation on this
tool, as well.
We're fairly far along in all of this implementation.
The core is most implemented.
The web console is mostly
implemented.
What we're working on right now are things
like dynamic graphs and version graphs.
But there is a
core functionality that you can easily use
at this point in the version that is available
to you.
The performance.
We benchmarked this performance against Neo4j.
For those of you who use these things,
Neo4j probably the state of the art.
It's a fairly expensive piece of software,
too.
So this is about 1.2 to 1.5 times faster on
larger data sets.
The reads and writes, it's 90/10 read-write
mix, similar
to Neo4j.
It's significantly faster than Neo4j on single
write performance.
The Compute Engine itself is significantly
faster, for example.
Trueno is about twice as fast as Neo4j on
things like
page rank, fairly simple benchmarks that we
run on these things.
So the bottom line is you can choose to use
Neo4j and pay a lot of money, which probably,
for most of the things that we choose to do,
do not get the same
performance as Trueno.
Finally, we show that this is very elastic.
If your throughput requirements go up, this
is very scalable.
You can
increase the number of executors and you can
get fairly good scaling on throughput as you
go through.
So this
brings us to the end of the infrastructure
part.
I will hand it off to Mehmet now, who can
talk about algorithms, and
we'll come back and talk of use cases in the
applications.
Mehmet.
Thank you, Ananth.
OK.
So Ananth has already mentioned, for example,
benchmarking Trueno for the PageRank
algorithm.
So one question you may have is, why do we
care about PageRank, right, in the context
of biological
network analysis.
So I will dive into that a little.
I will try to motivate a specific type of
query that you can run on these databases,
what we call network proximate
queries.
I will try to motivate it, and also, especially
for the computational audience, I will try
to show a few
examples of how interesting computational
problems can arise from this.
And how we solve from these problems.
And then we will go into applications of this.
So network proximate queries are essentially
based on the motivation that, say, we had
a set of nodes in these
networks, and these nodes can be proteins
that are identified in an experiment.
Right?
You compared a particle
experimental condition to another, to a control,
whatever.
And you identified some proteins as being
significantly
differentially expressed, significantly differentially
[INAUDIBLE] related.
So what you want to do is you want to ask
the question, what is the functional relationship
between them?
Why do
they show up together in an experiment?
And the second, can you also identify other
nodes, again, in these
networks that are function-relevant because
I want to be able to functionally notate my
[INAUDIBLE].
Right?
So of course, this is not limited to just
proteins that are identified in an experiment,
but for example, if you have
variants that you identify as being associated
with a disease, again, the same question is
there, right?
What is the
functional connection between them?
And then if I already know some variants that
are experimentally related.
I want to be able to use them to rent
other candidates that I may have.
So these types of questions are endless in
the context of biological exploration.
The nodes, as I said, are not just limited
to molecules or genomic variants.
But any biological entity, like a function,
like a pathway, like a disease, like a species,
like an organism can be thought of as nodes
in these networks.
So for example, then the network proximity
querying tries to answer this question, of
what is the functional
connection between them?
Or how can you identify additional nodes that
are functionally related to these query
nodes is when you map these nodes of interest
to the network, in here, for example, on B,
what you are seeing is
a clustered group of nodes.
If the query nodes are shown in black here,
then we could infer that the white nodes
around them are also probably functionally
related to the experiment that we have, to
the context that we have.
So
they have a good chance of being considered
also.
But if, for example, the query nodes are quite
dispersed and on the network, which you would
expect to happen in
random situations, then you will probably
have to do additional searches to see what's
going on here, and why
these proteins or why these nodes are dispersed
across the network.
And there could be different explanations
too.
So then the question is, how do we really
quantify the connectedness or the closeness,
or the proximity, between
different nodes in a network?
So to motivate information flow-based algorithms--
and these algorithms have been
used tremendously in the last 5, 10 years
in the context of network analysis.
So I have this simple example.
Here, what I am showing is three hypothetical
pairs of nodes.
There's s1 and t1, s2 and t2 and s3 and t3.
So when
I ask you the question of, which one which
s-t pair is most likely to be associated with
each other, just based on
this network topology, I believe many will
disqualify [? s-t ?] and t3 because the node
that connects them seems to
be very connected.
So they are in direct connection through a4
can be arbitrary and may not mean much.
But for example, if you look at s2 and t2,
there are multiple paths connecting them.
So the network topology
suggests that actually, they may be talking,
they may be related to each other.
And at the [? instance ?] of
dynamic information on biological networks,
really, the models that we have for these
networks are quite, quite
crude, in the sense that, really, all we know
is whether they bind to each other physically
or they are functionally
associated, and so on so forth.
A useful measure of network proximity comes
in the form of information flow-based models,
and there are lots of
information flow-based algorithms to assess
network proximity.
So these include, for example, effective
resistance, random walk with restarts, network
propagation, network defusion, defusion state
distance, et cetera.
And as I said, this has been used a lot in
the context of biology.
But almost always by downloading the [? attained
?] bug and then writing, developing your own
code, and then analyzing your data in your
own servers instead of
running queries on these.
And of course, this is also [? from the ?] applications
in other domains, like link
prediction, recommender systems, and of course,
we querying.
And that's where the name Google PageRank--
the name PageRank comes from.
So one of the information flow-based algorithms
that is popular is Random Walk with Restarts.
And a
mathematical formulation is out there, but
the general idea is this.
So what you do is you have a network and you
have one or more query nodes.
Let's assume that you have one query node,
for simplicity, but really, usually, in
the context of the biological applications,
usually you have multiple query nodes.
Because, again, the query nodes
that you are interested in are usually-- the
purpose of the query is really to understand
the functional connection
between your query nodes.
But for simplicity, let's assume that we have
one query node.
And the mathematical model for random walks
is to
simulate a random walk on the network such
that you start from with the node of interest,
from the query node.
And then you make a random move to its neighbors,
to one of its neighbors, and you keep going
until a certain
point.
After that point, you come back.
You jump back to your origin.
And keep doing the random walk, often jumping
back to the query node.
So if you let this go until infinity, if you
let this go forever, this walk go forever,
then the
proximity of each node in the next [? work
?] to your query node is defined as the probability
of the walk curve
being in that node at infinity.
So you can use an algebraic framework to represent
this model.
Essentially, you can represent this as a system
of
linear equations where you have a metrics
that presents a network and then essentially
the proximity vector that
you are looking for is the xq here.
And rq is your query data.
And of course, it is difficult to compute
this directly, so usually, people compute
this iteratively.
At some point, you
start with a guess, and then you keep updating
your guess.
And eventually, you converge to the stationary
distribution, which gives you the proximity
of each of your nodes to your query node.
So this is being used in the context of disease
gene prioritazation, for example.
Disease gene prioritization is a
problem that-- it came from [? genome-wide
?] linkage analysis, where you do your linkage
analysis on a limited
set of samples so the part of the genomic
region that you identify as being associated
with the disease of interest
is usually quite large and it can contain
hundreds of genes.
So one question is, how do you range these
genes according to their potential functional
relevance to the
disease?
And as early as 2007, algorithms that use
networking information have been developed
for this purpose.
So the idea in network information is, for
example, if you have a set of candidate proteins
that have coding genes
in the region that you identify as being associated
with the disease, then you just go ahead and
identify their
interacting neighbors.
And then you look at what types of diseases
their neighbors are implied in.
And based on that, you score each of
them, based on the diseases that are associated
with the neighbors of each candidate.
And the candidate that is
associated with most similar diseases has
good potential to be associated with your
disease.
So again, these were developed as early as
2007.
And the first algorithms that have been developed,
first
methods that have been developed in this context,
really, have treated the networks as a bag
of interactions.
Rather than including the network context,
they would just look at immediate neighbors.
But then came algorithms that recognize the
need for looking at network context, and again,
based on the
modulation with multiple paths between different
nodes in a network might be indicative of
their functional
association.
Information flow-based algorithms that use,
for example, random walk with restarts, or
network
propagation, have been developed for this
particular problem.
So you have a set of candidates that are potentially
associated with a disease.
How do you rank them, in terms of their functional--
potential function associated with the disease?
So your query
genes here become the genes that are already
known to be implicated in a disease that is
similar to your disease.
And then based on that, you rank your candidates
according to the random walk-based proximity
to the query
genes.
But information flow-based algorithms have
an important problem.
And I think I wanted to share this in this
particular webinar because I think it's always
important to be aware of this issue.
So either for biological or just for
experimental, or even just human-related reasons,
in biological networks, some of the nodes
will be very well
connected.
OK.
So this might be a protein with a very general
biological function, or this might be a protein
that is well-studied
just because it is interesting.
But some proteins have a high degree, but
many of them have very low degree.
So if you do this decision prioritization,
and if you use an information flow-based algorithm
to do the ranking, what
you are seeing here is that the algorithms,
the information flow-based algorithms will
do great if your node is very
well connected.
But if your node is not well connected, either
because it is not well studied, or just because
it has a
very specific function, really your algorithm
will never get studied.
So we developed algorithms to deal with this
issue.
And the algorithms that we developed essentially
assess
network similarity-- I would say the topological
similarity between two nodes-- not in terms
of network proximity,
but in terms of the similarity of their network
profiles.
So for example, here, if you look at this
hypothetical
example, in this network, although nodes 10
and 12 are not very close to each other, their
proximity profiles-- in
terms of their proximity to other nodes--
are very similar.
So this may implicate that they may have a
functional relationship.
But for example, the node that is labeled
12,
and the node that is labeled three are quite
far from each other.
And you can also see this by looking at, again,
their profile, in terms of their proximity
to other nodes.
So we have shown that this works nicely.
This improves-- this is gene prioritization
candidate.
This is gene
prioritization quite a bit over information
flow-based algorithms.
And it also discovers things that other algorithms
cannot discover because they are always overlooked.
But the catch here is, really, this is even
more expensive because to be able to do that,
you have to generate
these topological profiles, these proximity
profiles, for all nodes, and it's pretty expensive
computationally.
But if
you can see-- really, if you take into account
this degree bias, then you can develop algorithms
that are not
affected by degree bias that much.
But to avoid computing all these proximity
profiles-- the network proximity profiles--
what can you do?
Well, one
thing that you can do is acknowledge the fact
that these are huge networks, right?
There are thousands of
proteins, tens of thousands of biological
functions.
Many organisms, if you connect their networks,
then this will
give you, probably, networks with hundreds
of thousands of nodes, maybe millions of edges
and so on, so forth.
So these are huge.
And probably, the information for each node
in these networks lies around its close neighborhood.
So instead of
really computing these proximity vectors by
[? all, ?] what you can do is you can just
try to identify the K, and K
being a magic number here.
It can be 1,500-- I don't know-- depending
on your application, depending on the
user's needs who is querying these networks,
or 10.
We can define the problem as identifying the
top K, most proximate nodes to a query node,
or to a set of query
nodes.
In the data mining community, people have
studied these problems.
And the idea usually that is employed
is either use the structural properties of
the networks to avoid doing the entire computation
and just quickly walk
around the query nodes.
And by using the structure, they can stop
immediately after you are sure that you found
the K closest nodes.
Or
use the convergence properties of the iterative
computation and our understanding of [? molecular
?] linear
algebra and [INAUDIBLE] modeling of the residual
data that you have with each iteration.
[INAUDIBLE] to make a
quick stop.
Instead of really going on to converence,
stop when you are sure that you have found
the top K entries
in the proximity vector that you never want
to compute.
So what we did around this line was used Chebyshev
acceleration for this purpose.
So the idea here is,
essentially, in the context of that iterative
computation, what you can do is, instead of
using the iterative [? steps--
?] the iterative that you use for the proximity
vector itself-- you can use it in your combination.
And if you're using it
in your combination with Chebyshev polynomials,
you can show that linear combination will
converge to your
desired proximity vector more quickly than
the iterite itself.
So using this nice result, you can also bound
the error that you make at each iteration,
essentially, how much you
deviate from the actual solution.
And use that again to decide when to stop
when you identify the top K closest
neighbors.
And also, although I said, you need a linear
combination of the formula iterates, you can
really still do it
without storing all the iterates, without
increasing the storage at all.
So you can think of the idea here as also
remembering-- in the context of the random
walk on the network, what
you are doing is you are remembering where
you pass through.
Instead of just looking at the future, you
also look
at the past and remember.
You look back and remember where you are coming
from.
So that is what you are
doing by also looking at the previous iterates.
And again, this can be done quite efficiently.
And when you test this on networks with millions
of nodes, what you see is over standard [INAUDIBLE]
iteration
this type of acceleration will start much
more quickly.
So here, what you are looking at is, on the
x-axis, the
number of iterations for each dataset.
And the y-axis is how much you are away from
the actual solution.
So the
red curve converges much more fast compared
to blue curve.
So the consequence of this is, for example,
depending on how many nodes you are trying
to identify, either 4 or 8
or 32-- of course, if you are trying to identify
a larger number of nodes that are closer to
your query, then you will
have to iterate more.
So that's why the number of iterations goes
up, sK goes up.
But as you can see, the red
curve, which is Chebyshev's acceleration,
does it still in much less number of iterations,
as compared to other
methods that use either the structure of the
network or just the basic properties of the
iterative computation--
basic [? medical ?] properties of the iterative
computation.
So this is quite fast.
And then also, there is one parameter in these
competitions always, the alpha perimeter.
I think I didn't talk about
that when I first introduced the concept of
random walk with restarts.
So the parameter alpha here controls how
much, how local you want to make your search.
So with a larger alpha, then you keep going
back to your query node again and again.
Whereas for smaller alpha,
you don't keep going back that much, so the
network context becomes more important, and
the choice of alpha--
usually most algorithms are robust to this
choice of alpha, but it can still be important,
in terms of also the
computational efficiency and the accuracy
of your results.
So this particular algorithm that I am talking
about, the Chebyshev acceleration.
Also depending on whether your
search is local or more global, the improvements
in computational performance will depend on
whether you
search is local or global.
So again, for smaller alpha, your search is
more global.
For larger alpha, your search is
more local.
So for more global search, this type of acceleration
will be more useful.
Because for local search, the
problem is much easier.
So then, motivated by this, we have also developed
algorithms to make these even faster.
Because still, if you
think about integrating different types of
biological networks into this huge network,
even after Chebyshev [? sK ?]
acceleration, the time that is required to
process these queries may not be real times.
Still, we may have to wait
for minutes to process a query.
So thinking about how we can further accelerate
this, one idea that we have just
implemented and verified that it works is
to index some of the solution.
So essentially, since this is a linear system,
what you can do is you can always take the
inverse of the matrix that
is involved, store that matrix, and then when
a query comes, you can just multiply that
inverse with [? two-query ?]
vector, and you are done.
You have the solution.
So it is just one matrix make the [INAUDIBLE]
application that you need to do during query
processing.
But when
you do that, I mean, the problem with that
is for such a large network, the inverse will
be dense-- computing
inverse will be very difficult.
It will require the aid of memory.
And storing that inverse will take a lot of
storage.
So
it's not really feasible to index it.
But the key observation is that these networks
are highly sparse.
As I said before, in these networks, most
of the
nodes will be very loosely connected.
They will have just one, two, three neighbors.
So what you can do is you can use graph partitioning
to divide this network into one dense chunk.
And then these
very little parts that are loosely connected
within each-- maybe that are a little densely
connected within each
other, but loosely connected to the network.
And the matrix that corresponds to network,
if you re-order your
matrix according to the graph partitioning,
what you will get is a very large, but very
sparse, network that is shown
as M11 here.
And a very dense but small network that is
shown as [? M22 ?] here, and an M12 and M21
are the
connections between these parts of the network.
But now what you can do is you can take the
inverse of M11 and index that.
And you can solve the part of the
linear system that corresponds to M22 using
the iterative computation that I described
just a few minutes ago.
And
then you can integrate these solutions at
query time, and this turns out to be really,
really fast.
So comparing these million [INAUDIBLE] networks
like that, what we were able to see is if
you try to index the
entire inverse-- that's the purple bar that
you are looking at there-- essentially, it
will only work on small networks.
We are not even able to get results on larger
networks because, again, it's not scalable.
But if you index in such a way that you divide
the network into two parts, where one part
is large and sparse, the
other part is small and dense, then you will
increase your index size slightly.
So compared to, for example, the red
method that it uses just the iterative computation--
so if you are just using iterative computation,
all you need to
store is the matrix itself, or the network
itself.
So you are [? relying ?] a bit on that storage,
but the improvements in query time that you
are getting is two orders
of magnitude faster than the standard iterative
computation.
So this is very promising in terms of really
making
real time integrated querying of biological
networks possible.
So once these are integrated into Trueno,
essentially, we will be able to deliver these
type of queries in real time within seconds,
probably.
So the first application that I will talk
about-- and I will just briefly go through
this, and then pass it to Ananth so that
he can talk about even more exciting applications.
So one thing that we did, in utilizing these
algorithms, in terms
of discovering biological networks, was applying
this to predicting drug response in cancer
cell lines.
So for that
purpose, we downloaded data.
Again, as you can see, we downloaded the data.
So we are not still quite there, in terms
of querying the data
directly from the databases.
But we are getting there.
So this is a really encouraging, nice experiment,
showing
that we can get there.
So we downloaded two types of cell line datasets
with drug treatment with different cancer
drugs.
So one of them
is the GDSC.
One of them is downloaded from GDSC, the Genomic
of Drug Sensitivity in Cancer.
It's about 700
cell lines, and screened for under 40 drugs.
And the Cancer Cell Line Encyclopedia contains
about 500 cell lines
that are screened for 24 drugs.
And if you have ever [INAUDIBLE] this problem,
this is a quite-- you will know that,
from a machine learning perspective, this
is a quite difficult problem.
And actually, there are lots of competitions
trying to make this possible.
So then what we did is we developed a heterogeneous
network model representing all the information
that is in
these databases.
So the orange nodes show the drugs, the blue
nodes show the cell lines.
The green nodes show
the genes, and an edge between a cell line
and a gene shows that the gene is mutated
in the cell line.
A purple
edge between a cell line and a drug shows
that that cell line is sensitive to the drug,
and the pink edge shows that
a cell line is resistant to the drug.
And then the edges, the yellow edges between
the genes show that those genes
are coding for proteins that are functionally
or physically interacting.
So using this heterogeneous network, then
can we predict drug response for cell lines?
So the framework for that
is-- so we separate the networks based on
these pink edges versus the dark blue edges
to create sensitivity
networks that are representing sensitivity
to drug, and networks that are representing
resistance to drug.
Then we do these network proximity queries
by representing the drug as the query node,
and then we try to
identify a profile-- the proximity profile
for the drug.
So the proximity profile, if you will, will
be essentially the genes
that are mutated or that are close to the
mutated genes in the cell lines that are either
sensitive to the drug, as in
the sensitive network, or resistant to the
drug, as in the resistance network.
Then we look at the similarity between these
profiles.
And by comparing the similarity between the
resistance
profiles versus the sensitivity profile, we
predict whether a given cell line is responsive
to a drug.
And when we test
this on the GDSC dataset using leave-one-out
cross-validation-- the idea in leave-one-out
cross-validation is you
are removing one edge in the network at a
time, one edge being an edge between a drug
and a cell line.
You are
removing that and you are trying to see whether
you can predict that edge.
So the x-axis here represents the sensitivity
score.
The y-axis represents the resistance score.
And the color code
represents the [? IC50 ?] [INAUDIBLE], which
represents the response to the drug.
And it is not used in the
predictions.
So as you can see, the predicted [INAUDIBLE]
can cluster the drug cell line pairs based
on the [? IC50 ?]
[INAUDIBLE] quite well.
So then we looked at the [INAUDIBLE] patterns
of this by using the area under the curve
as a performance criterion.
And we have seen that this was quite robust
to the parameter that was involved in the
network proximity computations.
And actually, [INAUDIBLE] that parameter became
one, which means that the network was not
important at all at
this point.
Only the mutation information was used.
The performance went down, showing that the
network
information is quite variable.
And interestingly also, when we do the training
on one database, and then when we do predictions
on the other
database, with no cross- [INAUDIBLE] between
databases.
And Also, this is completely honest validation
where
really, you are using completely independent
databases with very different properties.
Still we were able to predict
drug response for the cell lines and CCLE.
Much, much better [INAUDIBLE] available area
under the curve of
86%, which is pretty good for drug response
prediction.
Again, as I said, it's pretty difficult to
make predictions using molecular data.
So I will stop at this point, and I will
pass it on to Ananth so that he can talk about
two more exciting applications because we
have 10 minutes left.
Ananth?
Ananth.
I'm good, Mehmet.
I need the screen.
You need the screen.
OK.
Sorry about this.
Microsoft has a way of starting you at the
start, and I couldn't leave my screen at full
screen.
So
I'll talk about two more examples.
The first one gives you a sense of how you
construct tissue-specific
interactomes.
And so the problem is as follows.
I'll quickly summarize this because I do want
to leave some time for questions.
So the setting is actually quite commonly
encountered, where you have a set of genes,
and in order to [? actually
?] express, the greens are definitely expressed,
and the reds are not.
And you're trying to find, in this context,
what are the pathways that are significantly
implicated.
So here, A represents the original.
B, C, and D all represent different possible
alternatives for what might be the
implicated networks in this particular context.
So if you want to solve a problem like this,
you can actually set up a
very simple optimization problem.
What you do is you want to make sure that
you diffuse the pattern of
dysregulation through the network.
But you want to make sure that the entire
network doesn't get implicated in this
regulation.
So you have some kind of regularizer, which
is an L1 regularizer with suitable sum to
1 constraints
here.
And if you solve this, you can actually define
something called activity scores.
So you've taken your dysregulation,
you've defined activity scores.
You can use these activity scores with fairly
conventional computer science
techniques, things like Prize-Collecting Steiner
Trees.
And now you can start to actually find disease-specific
networks.
I'll give you two examples of Parkinson's
and
Alzheimer's.
And so what we do is we start from transcriptomic
data.
We find the dysregulated genes.
We
integrate networks with these dysregulated
genes.
And then we use this infrastructure that I
just mentioned to pull
out networks that are very specifically implicated
in a specific phenotypic context.
So these are simple examples, but you can
actually do a much broader study.
In this particular case, we pulled
out context-specific networks from a number
of diseases.
And here we show the P values of the compactness
of
the disease-implicated networks.
So once again, here, low P value means that
you're much more likely to find
disease-implicated genes within these sub
networks that you pulled out.
And in each of these cases, you will notice
that the method that we have, which is [INAUDIBLE]
85, gives you
really good P-values.
The aggregate P-value is 3.7 times 10 to bar
minus 19, which tells you that these networks
that we're pulling out are very, very specific
to the disease contexts for which we pulled
out the transcriptomic
data.
So it's a really clean example of how you
can build context-specific networks.
I'll just quickly summarize one more
very recent paper.
I think this will appear in Nature Communications
within the next two weeks.
And this applies
similar network techniques to single cell
data.
And here, the idea is you have a large number
of single cell profiles.
How do you find a network context, or network
underlying these single cell transcriptomic
profiles?
So here's an example of something that we
pulled off.
These were about 80,000 cells, so think of
these as 80,000
So here's an example of something that we
pulled off.
These were about 80,000 cells, so think of
these as 80,000
transcriptomic profiles derived from, I think,
about tens of patients-- about 20 patients
here.
And these were
melanoma patients.
So in this particular case, after all of the
post-processing that we do based on what is
called a principal Convex-
Hull analysis, you can recast all of those
cells in a lower dimensional space.
And you see these really neat clusters
that start to pop out.
So these are, for example, the NK CD80 cells.
These are the CD4 T-cells.
But really, the
cluster you're interested in is the tumor
cluster here.
And you find some very interesting sub-clusters
within this cluster, as well.
So the most conventional differentiation
that you see is based on the expression of
this metF gene, metF high or metF low.
This is what is clinical practice
right now.
But we, in fact, show that there are other
clusters, as well.
We pull out the networks associated with these
clusters.
So we take one of those archetypes.
We look at all the transcription factors and
the dysregulated genes.
We can find all the drug targets and we can
show very different survivability for all
of these genes, as well.
So this is another example of how you can
use all
the way from transcriptomic data down to networks
to really, really target precision medicine
down to a cell, not
just an individual.
So to conclude, network models are very effective
ways of representing, analyzing disparate
data.
Network
topology matters, and there are massive computational
challenges.
I think we're at a point where we have made
significant progress.
We've made progress in the software infrastructure.
We've made progress in the
methodological space.
And we've been able to show some really compelling
applications, as well.
So a number of wonderful students and colleagues
worked on this.
Our acknowledgments to the National Institute
of Health, the National Cancer Institute,
and specifically, to the BD2K Program.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, gentlemen.
This was really, really interesting.
Looks like a very interesting tool.
I want to ask any of
our audience members to please text in any
questions that you might have.
To kind of kick things off on a couple
of questions in the time that we have left,
I was curious-- I didn't quite pick it up,
and perhaps you touched on this
and I missed it, but are the networks-- you
have adjacency matrices, which I presume are
just like 1's and 0's.
Can
you have weighted networks, as well?
Can those networks be directed graphs, or
are those not possible, or add
extra levels of complication?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
But I can answer, as well.
Would you like to go ahead, Mehmet?
It's fine for me.
OK.
Let me try to answer and then you can add.
So yes, essentially, [INAUDIBLE] are an important
part of these networks because, for example,
for interactions between proteins, it's either
your confidence on the
existence of that interaction, or the affinity
between the proteins usually has to be taken
into account.
And there
have been several studies that have showed
that if you take into account such confidence,
or affinity scores, then
usually, your utilization of the network will
be more effective, in terms of uncovering
true biology.
So those really
matter.
In terms of directed networks, yes, most of
these edges have to be directed because, for
example, for a [? regular
?] interaction, right?
If a gene acts on the other, if the gene regulates
the other, then you need to be able to
encode that information.
So in the database, you can easily account
for this.
But in terms of the analytics, in terms
of the algorithms that are involved, or in
terms of the query that you define on this,
you may lose that information.
So the proximity queries that I have talked
about today can be made to take into account
or ignore the direction,
depending on whether you want to include that
information or not.
If you want to include direction, then you
may
need to be more specific on how you want to
incorporate it because the way that I define
network proximity, it was
essentially, how close you are in the network.
So when the direction comes into play, it
may be more difficult to semantically define
that.
So Ananth, if you would
like to add anything to this.
Sure.
And by way of the software infrastructure,
the edge and the node schemas are very rich.
You can store
arbitrary information on both the edges and
the nodes.
For example, on the edges, you may want to
have a time
series.
These are interactions that change the time,
so you can actually put a complete time series
on the edges,
in addition to directionality and all the
other attributes you might want.
The node schema itself is arbitrarily rich.
You can put time series or any other information
on the node schema, as
well.
So the software admits all of these-- the
database completely supports all of these.
I'm glad you brought that up.
I was going to ask about how whether or not
you could do things to the edges and
make queries on the edges and what have you.
Absolutely.
Yeah, yeah.
That's interesting.
One final question before we have to go is
this looks like a really fantastic tool for
training and
education.
And I was curious if it's possible, and perhaps
it is, to synthetically break a network to
be able to load
one in and maybe, with a pair of digital scissors,
go and clip some connections or turn some
nodes off.
And then
watch what happens when you've done that.
And that can happen, you know, as a training
exercise.
Is that
something that you have pursued?
So the basic database does not have this functionality.
But it's absolutely-- I mean, if this is a
kernel or an analytics
kernel that people believe is important, it
would not take us very long to code this into
the database.
Of course,
you could code this yourself, but even if
you wanted us to code it, it wouldn't take
very long.
It would just be a
bunch of graphics queries to remove a few
nodes or remove a few edges to separate the
vertex.
The [? vertex ?]
the graphic could do.
You could do this through the web API.
That's easily done, at this point.
But beyond that, you would have to code
what it is that you're trying to do with the
two sub networks that you get.
But your point is very well-taken.
I think
such experiments really need to be set up.
The core infrastructure is there.
We need to set up these experiments
beyond that.
Well, that's great.
Well, it looks like we are out of time.
I want to think Ananth and Mehmet for their
presentation.
This looks like a very valuable tool, and
one I'm going to actually go and take a look
at once I get back to the US.
I'm abroad right now.
But this looks like a great tool.
I hope others will do that, as well.
I want to thank you guys again, and I want
to thank all of our audience members for joining.
We expect to have
the video of this up and online later today.
And in the meantime, thank you very much.
And everyone, enjoy the
rest of your day, or enjoy your weekend.
Thanks again, everybody.
Thank you.
Have a safe trip.